براسكري ذلك 6
حضر النساء من العمل بالمنظمات غير
الحكوميه ومسؤول اماميه يلتقي سلطات
طالبان اليوم
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
تدعوا لمحاسبه ايران على ملاحقاتها
القضائيه للمحتاجين ومخاوف من اعدامات
جديده
باعاده الحريه للاوكرانيين والبدء في هدم
مسرح ماريوفيل الذي تفهم اوكرانيا روسيا
في قصفه في مارس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير
تابع للامم المتحده في افغانستان رامز
في المنظمات غير الحكوميه وقال الرسول
الاممي انما حدث سيؤثر بشكل خطير على
عمليه شهور الانسانيه والاغاثه لافغانستان
الى جانب ان برامج الامم المتحده ستتاثر
وقالت وكاله المعونه الدوليه
ان تعليق العمليات حدث على الفوق يعني
اكثر
من جانبه حضر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه من
ان قرار طالبات بمنع نساء بين العامل في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه
سيعطل تسليم المساعدات وقد يكونوا مدمرا
لافغانستان
على موقع تويتر انه يشعر بقلق عميق من ان
قرار طالبان سيعطل المساعده الحيويه
والمنقده لحياه الملايين
اما الاتحاد
الاوروبيان عمل النساء في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان
على مساله تقديم المساعدات الى البلاد
لدى المنظمات غير الحكوميه بالحجاب ولم
يتضح بعض ان كانت التوجيهات الجديده تشمل
الاجنبيات العائلات في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان
ويعبر اتحاد الاوروبي من ابرز الجهات
المموله لمنظمات الاغاثه العامله في
افغانستان لكنه لا يعترف رسميا بحكومه
طالبا
حركه طالبان تواصل حملتها ضد النساء في
افغانستان لحرمانهن من التعليم والعمل
وزاره الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان خطبت
المنظمات غير الحكوميه الاجنبيه والمحليه
بتعليق توظيف النساء وهددت بالغاء رخص
العمل في حال عدم الامتثال لاوامر الحركه
على المنظمات الاهليه تعليقات توظيف
النساء وفي حال عدم الالتزام بالامر ستلغى
رخصه التشغيل الخاصه بالمنظمات
وفي محاوله لتبرير قرار الحركه في منع
توظيف النساء قالت وزاره الاقتصاد ان
الامر يعود لعدم التزامهن بالزي الذي
حددته طالبان
اوامر حركه طالبان الجديده اثار السجالات
ومخاوف من احتمال ان تسري على وكالات
الامم المتحده والمنظمات الانسانيه التي
لها وجود كبير في افغانستان
اعلنت ايضا ان بعض الجامعات ستغلق لمده
اسبوع بسبب احتجاجات بعد الطلاب على منع
التعليم النساء مبرره الامر بعدم جاهزيه
تلك الجامعات وان كانت بعض مقاطع الفيديو
على مواقع التواصل قد اظهرت اطلاق النار
على الطلاب
قرارات حركه طالبان بمنع الطالبات من
الحضور الى الجامعات وعدم اكمال تعليمهن
اثار انتقادات دوليه حاده واحتجاجات ضد
اسرار طالبان على تهميش دور المراه وتقويض
وجودها بالقوه جاسم محسن العربيه
بالوقوف ضد قرارات حركه طالبان
الى مغادره العاصمه كابور
فتيات في افغانستان
ضد النساء
انشوده
بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي باستمراري اداره
الرئيس في محاسبه المسؤولين الايرانيين
عما وصفته بالعنف العشوائي ضد الاحتجاجات
في ايران قالت اللجنه عبر حسابها على
تويتر بقوه على تزايدي وتيره الملاحقات
القضائيه وتنفيذ احكام الاعدام من جانب
النظام الايراني
قالت ناشطه الايرانيه مسيحيه لنجاد
المقيمه في الولايات المتحده ان النظام
الايراني او دعا المدونه الايرانيه في
تحقان نسيمي معتقل كما شاب في الارض وان
ذويها قلقون من ان يحكم عليها النظام
بالاعدام
[موسيقى]
حكم
[تصفيق]
تتحول الساحات في ايران من بقع المكتظه
بالمتظاهرين الى ميادين موت علنيا
بالرفيعات هكذا يريدها النظام الايراني
ليخمد اصوات التظاهرات بحسب منظمه العفو
الدوليه التي وصفت هذا المشهد بالمحاكمه
الصوريه التي تهدف الى ترهيب المحتاجين
اعدم شخصان هذا الشهر محسن شكاري ومجيد
رضا رهن ورد وكيلاهما لم يتجاوز عمره 23
ربيعا واعداد الاعدادات الوشيكه متضاربه
ما بين 21 نسبه لبيانه العفو الدوليه
وثلاثه واربعين وفق شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه وصولا الى 100 نقلا عن منظمه
حقوقيه لكن اسمين اخرين كانت المحكمه
العليا اعلنت انها قبلت حكم استئنافهما
معلله ذلك بقصور في تحقيقات محمد اقباله
وثمان سيدي ياسين
ثم ما لبث الخبر ساعات حتى تراجعت عن
اقوالها ووافقت على اعدام اقباله مضيفه ان
الاعتراض الذي ورد في ملفه مرفوض من قبل
المحكمه المعنيه التي قالت ان اقبادله
يواجه حكما بالاعدام بسبب مهاجمته افراد
الشرطه بسياره 100 يوم مضت ولم تخفث
التمديدات الغاضبه التي تصاحبها حمله
اعتقالات طالت ما لا يقل عن 18,000 من
الغاضبين من النظام ورموزه اما القتله
فتجاوز عددهم ال 470 شخصا في حصيله غير
نهائيا اسراء الصغير العربيه
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
عاصفه ثلجيه تشل الحياه في الولايات
المتحده وبعض انحاء كندا عشيه اعياد
الميلاد
اوكرانيا تحولت بسبب الحرب الى حقل تجارب
للاسلحه وتقريه القتال الحديثه طرفه الحرب
يستخدمون ما توفر في ترسانتهم لتحقيق
التفوق على الخصم
حتى في اخر خطاباته خطاب الصناعه العسكريه
الروسيه على زياده الانتاج مطالبا للمجمع
الصناعيه العسكري للاستفاده من الخبرات
المكتسبه من الحرب لتطوير ترسانه موسكو
الصفه الابرز في الحرب القائمه في اكرانيا
هي الاعتماد على الطائرات المسيره
كالكلاشنكوفيه روسيا كذلك لجات الى
التصنيع الايراني الرخيص للحصول على
المسيرات المفخخه لضرب البنيه التحتيه
الاخرانيه
لكن لدى موسكو اسلحه اكثر تطورا تستخدمها
ضد اهداف مهمه كما قر القياده والسيطره
ومخازن السلاح الاوكرانيه كالصواريخ
المجنحه كاليبر التي يتراوح مداها بين
1500 كيلومتر اما اوكرانيا فاعتمدت على
مسيره بيرك دار التركي في بدايه الحرب ثم
توالت عليها المساعدات من حلفائها
الغربيين فحصلت على سويتش بليد وفينك
الاخيره واشنطن ستدخل منظومه الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت لساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا
العربيه
بدات سلطات المواليه لروسيا في مدينه
مريول بهدم البصره مسرح المدينه التي قالت
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه قصفته في السادس
عشر مارس صور التي التقطتها شركه ماكسار
الاقمار الصناعيه تظهر مدى الضرر الذي
اصاب المسرح قبل
[موسيقى]
قررت السلطات الفرنسيه رفع قرار احتجاز
المشتبهي بقتله ثلاثه كرات في باريس
بالفعل الى مركز للعلاج النفسي تابع
للشرطه قالت نيابه العامه في باريس ان
الطبيب الذي فحصل مشتبه به خالص الى ان
الوضع الصحي له لا يتوافق مع اجراء
الاحتجاز
او قاضي حقيقي
[موسيقى]
وزاره الداخليه العراقيه تهديدات
الارهابيه لا تزال موجوده في بعض البنادق
البعيده والنائيه في البلاد وقال المتحدث
باسم وزاره الداخليه خالد المحنه ان
الايام المقبله ستشهد تنفيذ ضربات وصفها
بالموجعه لتنظيم داعش
مجلس سياده سوريه
في الاعتراف باي تقصير او تجاوز صاحبه
اداء افراد او جماعات من الشرطه خلال
تنفيذ القانون
في ختام احتفالات عيد الشرطه لا كبير على
القانون و تشهد بذلك ساحات العداله للعديد
من المحاكمات
من الاجهزه المختصه تعمل على التحري
والتحقيق في جميع الجرائم التي صاحبت
الثوره
صحيفه السودان تريبيون باعلاني حاله
الطوارئ في ولايه جنوب دارفور بعد هجوم
المسلح على عده كره اصفر عن سقوط قتل
ومصابين قالت صحيفه حكومه جنوب دارفور
فوضت الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه باتخاب
كافه التدابير لحسن ما وصفته بالانقلاب
الامني
العيش في شمال سوريا صعوبه خاصه للفقراء
الذين يكابدون درجات الحراره المنخفضه
وارتفاع اسعار الخبز الناتج عن قله
المخصصات من دقيقه القمح
انخفاض شديد في درجات الحراره في الشمال
السوري يقابله ارتفاع في اسعار الخبز
ليفاقم ظروف العيش الصعبه في منطقه
القامشلي سوريا من اعمار مختلفه ينتظرنا
لساعات للحصول على بعض الخبز باسعار
مناسبه
وما نقدر نشتري ربطات خبز وتنام عرسان
الحمد لله رغم الظروف القاسيه الا ان
ملامح الانسانيه ما زالت موجوده تطوع هذا
الرجل السبعيني لتسجيل اسماء الباحثين عن
لقمه الخبز حتى لا يضطر الى المبيت في
الشارع
واحد وراء واحد ويروحون العالم كلها تفضل
من الشالات
الصبح يجي واحد اسمه محمود ياخذ هذا كلهن
ويصيح الواحد
الافران الشعبيه في القامشلي لا تتجاوز 15
فرنا
ومخصصاتها من دقيق القمح لا تتجاوز الطن
الواحد في حين ان حاجيات السكان تتجاوز
ثلاثه اطنان لكل فرن في ظل الاقبال الشديد
من اصحاب الدخل المحدود
عن العالم فقراء العالم عم يدور الرخص
العالم مساحه 3
اوضاع صعبه يعيشها الفقراء في الشمال
السوري في ظل المناشدات بتوفير كميات اكبر
من الدقيق للمخابز انس نماسي العربيه
مع الاحتفالات باعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
تشهد مدينه بيت لحم وسط الضفه الغربيه
وفود من شرق اسيا تتجمع في ساحه كنيسه
المهد مجموعه اوروبيه تتسوق من محلات بيع
التحف الشرقيه المنتشره في الجوار شبان من
امريكا يحتسون القهوه العربيه في المقاهي
لقد عادت رئه المدينه لتتنفس عاده السياحه
وعاد نبيل ينفض غبار الركود عن بضاعته
استعدادا لبيعها الحمد لله شهر 10 و11 في
مدينه بيت لحم كان في حركه سياحيه بشكل
يعني ملحوظ طبعا ما رجعنا للحركه اللي
كانت ما قبل الجائحه طبعا بنتمنى هلا
عندنا عيد الميلاد اعياد الميلاد حاليا
نتمنى حاليا انه يعني تكون هاي السنه حركه
اكثر مثل ما عم نسمع انه ان شاء الله
متراقبين حركه سياحيه هائله في مدينه بيت
لحم بعدها من عجاف انتشرت فيها الجيش
ومنعت التجمعات وتراجعات السياحه الى ما
دون الصفر زارا فلسطين من بدايه العام نحو
600 الف ساعه ويتوقع ان يستمر توافد
الالاف خلال الاسابيع القادمه نسبه
الاشغال في الفنادق وصلت لنحو مئه في
المئه والمصلون من شتى بقاع الارض يدخلون
ويخرجون من كنيسه المهد احنا قطعنا فتره
عن العالم واليوم رجعنا لحتى نشوف سياحه
جايه من كل مكان في العالم لحتى يزوروا
مكان ميلاد السيد المسيح وطبعا خصوصا في
اعياد الميلاد المجيده وتسع مدينه بيت لحم
حاليا لفتح شركات وتوقيع اتفاقيات
الخارجيه لاعاده السياحه لما كانت عليه
قبل الجاهه بحيث تستقطب المدينه سنويا
زهاء مليونين ونصف المليون زائر
في دون يوميا الى مدينه بيت لحم يشغلون
شوارعها وفنادعها ويتسوقون من متاجرهها
بالتزامن مع الاحتفالات باعياد الميلاد
وراس السنه
كل ذلك يعيد للمدينه شيئا من رونقها الذي
فقدته خلال الاعوام القليله الماضيه من
مدينه بيت لحم عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
20 22
[تصفيق]
القادم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بطني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حاله الطوارئ في جميع انحاء السودان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سجلت ليله عيد الميلاد في ولايه سقوط ثلوج
كثيفه غطت المنازل وسيارات وشوارع المدن
في الولايه
درجات الحراره بشكل غير
[موسيقى]
وجنوب الولايات المتحده يعاني مئات
المهاجرين المكسيكيين من البرد القارس
ودرجات الحراره المتدنيه والصقيع بانتظار
قرار الامريكي
[موسيقى]
مع عوده ابو كورانا للانتشار مجددا في
الصين حولت تسلطات المحليه في موقع طاعتك
جنوب الصين
ومراكز المعارض الى عيادات حمام مؤقته
لعلاج المرضى المصابين بفيروس
اكثر من 250 عاما
العلاج في الوقت المناسب للحالات التي
ظهرت عليها الاعظم
في الختام تذكير بالعناوين
امريكي اليوم
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
تدعوا لمحاسبه ايران على ملاحقاتها
القضائيه
من اعدامات جديده
ازيك يا ستي كريستيانو
[موسيقى]